[Musique]
bon parlons peu parlons bien nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec bouygues
telecom
j'aime pas trop quand c'est marqué c'est
que les petites bandes halls à soissons
ce côté de l'écran soit sur ce côté là
je trouve ça terrible comme ça les
choses sont claires c'est une vidéo qui
est réalisé en partenariat avec
bouteille pourquoi pour vous apporter
une info très importante je sais pas
vous comment vous utilisez internet à la
maison où est-ce que vous avez une bonne
collection wiz longue pas comment
d'ailleurs marqué le mois dès maintenant
en barrant commentaires comme ça on peut
en discuter on peut regarder ça
si c'est pas kg une solution qui peut
vraiment vous aider à améliorer
significativement vos commentaires
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent grâce à un partenariat
avec des télécoms
j'avais cette box la cette box la quête
une box fibre qui était cool qu'ils
allaient bien qu'ils allaient vite que
tu une box un petit peu standard wi-fi 5
qui marchait bien bonne collection fibre
c'était cool c'était bien mais c'était
sans compter la nouvelle box bouygues
telecom avec du wifi 6 avec une
collection toujours plus rapide et
surtout un design revu et corrigé
[Musique]
à
à chauny
m
hier
cette box c'est celle là celle là là on
passe quand même de ça à ça et là croyez
moi il ya un vrai avantage pour quoi
déjà parce que cet équipement voudrait
un produit qui permettent beaucoup plus
beau on est plus sur les codes de life
is est vrai que cette box là on peut pas
dire quelle vilaine mais elle n'apporte
pas grand chose et lorsque vous avez ça
chez vous vous avez plus tendance à le
cacher dans un coin à le mettre dans un
placard et mais pour certains d'entre
vous le mettre dans un tiroir dans un
placard fermé ce qui globalement est
assez une mauvaise idée parce que ça
bloque le signal mais ça veut dire
dégrader la qualité de votre wifi
[Musique]
là par contre on à l'appareil qui est
beau un appareil qui est sympa on peut
poser n'importe où et lorsque la caméra
chez vous il saura pas ce que c'est ce
sera un appareil domestique comme un
autre comme une amazone d'alexa comme
une enceinte quelconque on se dira ça se
produit c'est joyeux schengen alors
sachez le c'est pas une enceinte à cette
petite boîte là cette petite box elle ne
fait pas musique elle a un rôle est un
rôle unique et seul rôle et qu'elle fait
merveilleusement bien c'est le fait de
vous apporter une excellente connexion
internet en fibre on s'adresse donc ici
aux clients de bouygues telecom je pense
que ça vous aura pas échappé mais à tous
ceux qui sont éligibles ou qui ont déjà
de la fibre on n'est pas sur une box
adsl
on est sur une box fibre voilà il faut
le savoir il faut l'écrire noir sur
blanc
si vous n'avez pas la fille vous n'aurez
pas c2box si vous avez la fille vous
allez voir ça va venir améliorer
l'expérience de balle pourquoi la
première question qu'on soit au top un
petit produit comme ça c'est pourquoi
est ce que oui nous a fait un produit
verticale boîtes noires ça que ça change
par rapport aux codes classiques lorsque
vous aviez une box comme ça il boxe
toute blanche plutôt rectangulaire bon
un peu standard pour trouver un peu
partout et là on se retrouve sur une
espèce d'objet un peu différent plus
différenciant pourquoi est-ce que
bouygues telecom a fait le choix de nous
proposer un projet comme celui-là il ya
deux raisons principales la première
c'est que il faut effectivement amélioré
le signal lorsqu'on a une boxe un peu
classique on la planche et du coup ça
dégrade le signal ils se sont donc dit
en réfléchissant on brainstorm on dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et bien tout
simplement on va rendre l'objet de baux
que les gens n'est pas content et qu'il
puisse l'affiché oui à nous de
travailler dans ce sens là en terme de
design avec un objet élégant simple
facile à utiliser très intuitif sajoo le
monde en quelques instants
et surtout à la portée de tous c'est pas
vous mais moi ce que j'avais une box
comme ça et que je voulais venir à dents
mais paramétrage ou bien vous êtes dans
votre navigateur internet vous attaquez
votre adresse ip ou l'url raccourcie
pour accéder aux paramètres là dedans il
fallait souvenir du mot de passe est une
galère
déjà il fallait savoir comment rentrer
dedans fava c'était vraiment pas hyper
hyper simple et pas forcément fait pour
monsieur tout le monde surtout fait pour
des personnes qui avaient un petit peu
l'habitude de grattouiller de bidouiller
sinon se prenait rapidement la tête
lorsque vous la regardez comme ça vous
avez un écran qui est complètement nos
deux villes même pas qui vient saluer
mais lorsque vous vous rapprochez ça
c'est le capteur de présence
et puis surtout regardez vous avez trois
boutons enfin vous avez en réalité une
molette qui aussi un mode bouton vous
appuyez dessus vous avez petit bouton
wps le petit bouton pour valider ici et
vous avez un bouton pour venir activer
désactiver le wifi plage et désactiver
le wifi je re clique dessus je réactive
le wifi ça c'est simple
ouais
m
wang
ensuite venir naviguer voilà sa marque a
été mon iphone samuel marque dont kg
quelques infos ce qui est connecté sur
wii fit six as à la date le jour très
bien je tourne la jaquette dans mes
paramètres alors premier paramètre le
java ces connexions wifi là je pouvoir
nous connecter directement grâce à cuire
colton je prends mon smartphone je
flashe le code et ça nous connecte
directement mon appareil ici avec le qr
code et ça c'est vraiment génial on se
rend même pas compte qu'on a un écran en
fait c'est complètement dingue vraiment
sans vraiment pas content
l'âge et la messagerie vocale parce que
la branche effectivement un téléphone de
la même manière vous aurez le journal de
vos appels vous allez avoir ensuite ici
vos réglages réglages de l'écran vous
allez pouvoir régler si votre luminosité
très facilement de votre détecteur de
présence on off si vous souhaitez votre
wifi polignac calibré ici met une plage
horaire oui/non wifi 6 active et oui non
utilisés à norme wifi 5
si vous le souhaitez et un le wifi
régler des plages c'est très très très
simple les réglages de votre téléphone
confidentialité informations voyez on
n'a qu'à venir naviguer avec la petite
molette j'ai ensuite les événements que
je vais avoir qu'est-ce qui s'est
connecté hâter leur nouvelle collection
wi fi des nombreuses et toutes mes infos
sur les événements liés à ma boxe
caddies d'agnostiques très très très
simplement d'un moustique internet
feriana lise auto dépannage ça permet
vraiment de venir des grossiers avant
d'appeler le sav donc c'est vraiment
cool on va regarder la vitesse de
connexion alors en débit descendant on
est à combien directement dans la boxe
on est quasiment à 1 giga on entrait le
fils tué on n'est pas loin d'un giga 868
megabit par seconde et le débit montant
on est un peu plus de 500 mégabits par
seconde et ensuite je peux venir
redémarrer ma beaucoup ce dimanche à
leur pic à glace et malin parce qu'il
est vraiment optimisé pour la
dissipation de la chaleur on va donc pas
avoir une box qui va chauffer
surchauffée on est un produit qui est
extrêmement silencieux au delà du fait
qu'on avait du wifi cinq essais
canadiens wifi si donc on wifi on va
canal est beaucoup plus vous alors il
vous faut un smartphone avec du wifi 6
ou un ordinateur et du wifi si ce qui en
a pas beaucoup aujourd'hui il y en a
quelques-uns notamment celui à cette
petite bête l'iphone os promax qui
permettra en difficile d'avoir le
meilleur débit pour s'inspire test pour
voir ce que ça dit au wifi 6 gt monte à
9 cents et quelques méga bits par
seconde autrefois la 601 quelque 660 170
qui dit mieux ça va ça fonctionne mais
j'avais quand même beaucoup aidé à la
fage l'effet garder en un résultat
descendant à 675 ascendant à 272 on
s'inspire tests sur l'ancienne box en
wifi 5 de bouygues telecom mais on la
regarde et on a quand même beaucoup de
mal on monte à 220 230 mégabits par
seconde
250 c'est ce qu'on va faire les 300
peut-être qui dit mieux on s'en
rapproche mendie pas tout à fait encore
à est pas loin ça flirte à 1 et on le
passe à 300 mégabits par seconde est en
débit ascendant
on passe les deux sens va monter à
combien de 170 voyez résultat c'est
quand même sans appel 308 mégabits par
seconde en descendant ascendant 278
megabit par seconde et hyper drôle avec
ce résultat là c'est qu'en fait je suis
connecté à la fibre exactement de la
même manière et goûter à l'école j'ai
fait le test exactement ça même sans
mère de mon opérateur jusqu'à ici j'ai
le même débit de fibres ce qui va faire
la différence pour capter ici au wifi
c'est tout simplement ce que je captais
avec mon wifi 6 ou 6 5 ou 6 6 pour rien
ou vraie différence pour un peu négatif
de cette box à pourra que le coton qui
peut être à poussière alors là j'ai
vraiment fait le ménage de tous les
côtés c'est un petit peu électrostatique
à l'avant c'est pas non plus énorme mais
légèrement dont bon il faut quand même
passé de temps en temps un coup de
chiffon si vous passez un coup de
chiffon d'elle comme sur tous vos
meubles ça ira franchement ça va ça fera
le taf mais en plus ce qui est vraiment
génial c'est qu'elle est évolutive
vous allez pouvoir monter dans le futur
on n'est pas encore jusqu'à 10 giga pour
l'instant on a autour de 1 giga 10 gigas
vous y êtes pas encore mais lorsque ce
sera possible
et bien cette box vous permettra ça déjà
c'est bien avec le deuxième point il ya
tout qui était hyper mal de la porte du
télégramme c'est qu'en fait cette box là
elle pourra évoluer lorsqu'un client va
la changer qu'elle va repartir chez we
que paf il pourra l'ouvrir menthe et
dans les composants et elle repartira
comme neuve avec un duel gred ça s'est
vraiment bien alors le secret de cette
forme et de cette petite boutique grande
boxe même c'est la répartition des
antennes en fait rien n'est laissé au
hasard tout a été réfléchi
vous avez deux antennes de chaque côté
donc en gros vous avez 80 end autour des
mathématiques c'est très facile à faire
ça vient vraiment optimisé le signal par
million de capter de tous les côtés de
façon à ses directives
bien évidemment vous êtes du wifi on
devient une quasi guerre mais également
en 5 giga hertz
mais surtout il mobilisait pour moi un
des points forts se situe juste ici là
au niveau de la molette au niveau de
l'expérience globale ça ça change tout
autre point qui est vachement bien avec
le wifi si c'est que au delà d'avoir
effectivement plus de débit mais
envisage de collection ascendante
descendante et bien vous êtes aussi une
meilleure répartition entre tous vos
device vous n'avez aucun tu va se
retrouver en panne de connexion qui va
voir - débit parce que beaucoup consommé
deux côtés de toute façon vous arrivez
déjà avec de la fibre donc déjà derrière
vous avez du débit vous avez une bonne
répartition au niveau de la boxe à 360°
et grâce au wifi 6 vous êtes aussi bonne
répartition entre tous les devices ça
c'est vachement bien surtout quand on
voit les collectivités à youtube et à la
maison je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai
des anciens de côté tous les côtés jeu
des lumières collecter g1 d'ordi j'ai
une tablette j'ai une télé j'ai des
smartphones ce qui fait qu'au final avec
beaucoup d'objets connectés et c'est
d'ailleurs déjà vous avez un adsl que
vous avez du wifi 5 et bien un moment ça
pose problème tandis que là avec de la
fibre du wifi 6 me connecter tout ce
beau monde ensemble et ça c'est vraiment
merveilleux pour la maison connectée
bien évidemment pour profiter de cette
jolie type box et bien il faut que vous
abonner à bouter les corps parce que si
vous n'êtes pas abonnés bouygues telecom
vous n'aurez pas de box bouygues telecom
ça me paraît quand même relativement
logique ça fait un petit moment moins
que je suis équipé fibre de bouygues
telecom croyez moi ça marche tellement
bien et avec ça tu le petit bogue ça
marche encore mieux
j'espère tout ça vous aura donné des
informations des clés de réponse pour
améliorer votre fibre à la maison pour
améliorer votre collègue soit la maison
vraiment comprendre pourquoi est-ce
qu'un objet est important par rapport à
un autre pourquoi de passer d'une
ancienne boxe comme celle ci à une
nouvelle box comme celle-là ça apporte
vraiment quelque chose pourquoi est ce
qu'un vrai gain
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte 10 partout
ça ça vous aura éclairé marqué le mois
en bas en commentaires si vous avez des
questions vous pouvez y aller sur ce je
vous embrasse
je donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler des réponses mais la
ville s'est longtemps
on s'est pas fait la vie voilà allez les
gros bisous et à demain
à vous
[Musique]